one of the things we do during the
regular season on monday morning
superlatives coming out of the sunday
that was so what the hell 11 games
closest thing to a regular season sunday
that we're going to see for a while
chris let's do some superlatives what do
you got coming out of last night well i
think the um
i'm feeling dangerous okay it's going to
be my first award or superlative and
that goes right to
baker mayfield i mean to come out in a
preseason game like that uh again i know
we're all excited about the cleveland
browns but then
when the product on the field matches
what we're hoping for and there's not
even odell beckham jr or jarvis landry
out there what baker mayfield did i mean
holy hell batman i mean it's just lasers
all over the field perfect passes great
pocket presence and then the touchdown
pass i mean a 30-something yard or 20
what was it a 24-yard throw kind of into
a tight window perfectly thrown i just
was great to see i mean baker mayfield
his energy his talent you could see the
energy in the stadium there in cleveland
uh just was a really cool moment and and
what a way i know it's pre-season but
still it's a great way to start it it
just gives your team such a great
positive vibe
they had 37 000 plus there for a
scrimmage on saturday at first energy
stadium there is excitement for the
first time in a long time legitimate
plausible hope and excitement to the
point where i'm still concerned the bar
is a little too high they're going to
have to come out of the gates fast and
strong or you're going to have panic in
cleveland because they are expecting big
things and i'm a big believer in baker
mayfield as are you and i think he's
going to lead this team where it needs
to go you and i both believe they're
going to be in playoff contention they
may indeed make it but so far so good
for the browns in 2019. all right my
first superlative for today this is the
there's no competition until there is a
competition award the giants to their
credit they've taken a lot of criticism
yes this offseason for picking daniel
jones sixth overall when they had
another first round pick 11 spots later
for how they've handled odell beckham jr
how they did this how they've done that
do they have a plan who knows what the
hell the plan is the plan is there is no
plan and we're not telling you what the
plan is i think with daniel jones they
have a plan and the plan is to continue
to keep the ball in eli manning's hands
until they're ready to take it away and
give it to daniel jones and they're not
going to declare there's a competition
they're going to downplay it they don't
want the kid to fail they know it's not
good for him or them if he does fail the
bottom line is they thought enough of
him to be the sixth overall pick in the
draft he should be good enough to win
this job and i think if he wins the job
it's going to happen quietly it's going
to happen slowly and then it's going to
happen suddenly and we're going to find
out hey daniel jones is the guy and i
don't know when it's going to come chris
but you know the other part of this
genius and and that word gets used
sparingly with the g-men but the other
part of it is they are crafting a
scenario where the fans are going to
clamor for daniel jones and that's a
tough sell when they love eli manning
but i think the fans have come around to
the idea it's time for a change and if
you can make them want daniel jones it's
so much easier if you do go to jones and
he does have some struggles at first
because the fans are behind the idea of
sticking with him and letting him become
whoever he can be yeah so we'll see how
it plays out but certainly a great start
for him i mean you know we talked about
some of the rookie quarterbacks he
looked like he belonged he looks like he
more than belongs and i know it's
preseason game number one but first off
it's great that he got off to the start
he did because hey
he's been a lightning rod here in the
new york area i mean if he threw an
interception on the first drive oh this
is this is what we're talking about blah
blah so great job by him executing and
not only just executing physically the
ball again like we talked about with
some of these other guys it popped out
of his hand i mean he looks athletic in
the pocket he's got a good presence
about him calm demeanor and some of the
throws he made were great it was a a
great job not only by him but pat
shermer and some of the play calls they
had too to make sure he got off to a
good start so the negative narrative
didn't start i'm excited for it again i
know i was critical of the guy coming
out in the draft i did not think he was
a first round pick i'm a giants fan i
mean anybody should know that and i'm
rooting for him i'm rooting for the
giants uh and he's certainly answered
some of my questions and we'll see how
it goes through the rest of the
preseason but it was a real good damn
start i'll say that
all right what else you got by way of
superlatives on this friday morning you
know since it's i i don't want to go
rookie quarterback again but i'm going
to go rookie quarterback again you know
i'm going to go out to arizona where
this comment came from he is who he
thought he was right and i know that's
the old dennis green close enough you
are who you we thought they are whatever
the hell you're right i'm close enough
you know me in english we're not always
you you're you're you're you are who i
thought you are yeah a dumb blonde who
used to play football uh either way
either way kyler murray you and i were
texting i think it was like the third
throw like okay that we've seen enough
we're not we're not concerned anymore
and again it is preseason game one and
i'm not trying to make him into tom
brady yet but uh you just have a feel
for when guys are special and it just
looks special and it just pops off the
screen to you i mean just so comfortable
how he's controlling things of the line
of scrimmage oh i'm backed up on my own
three yard line no big deal zoom out
route oh zoom another out route oh let
me scramble or get on the run zoom on
the money i just uh he he looks like
he's going to be a superstar and you
could see why everybody's raving about
him in arizona right now
and and here's the thing chris all we
saw was him moving behind the line we
did not see him put the pedal to the
metal and take off that's the other
aspect of his game that will reveal
itself probably in the regular season
there's no reason to use it in the
preseason but maybe in one of these
games when he plays a little bit more
and next week's game against the raiders
nationally televised so we'll see
hopefully more of him than we did on
thursday night but he's still got that
it's that combination it's it's the mike
vick legs but the ability uh and i i
don't know
right yeah but but but look at how and
is it is it because he's so small that
it's so jarring when the ball comes off
of his hand the way that it does and it
has that kind of zip would it not be as
stunning if he was 6'4 well
maybe i mean it is a little bit of the
emotion and theatrics of how he throws
it right uh but it's just such a quick
release and he can do it from so many
different angles and it's just explosive
and how he kind of loads it up and does
all that he's got great mechanics so
yeah it's like a little bit like brett
favre where you just it just i don't
know it looks cool or patrick mahomes or
aaron rod just looks cool when he does
it i don't know what it is about him but
he looked like he belonged and you can
see that the kid's got some special
attributes about his game you can
already tell the players like totally
believe in them not only just reading
the comments just the way they act with
them and interact with them on the
sidelines on the field so uh arizona
cardinals got to feel good right now
i think the decision to draft him first
overall already validated can you
imagine how the cardinals would feel
today if they were watching the
highlights of murray's first performance
again it was limited but it's like yeah
he passes the eyeball test yes he brings
it to the next level there's a lot more
that he needs to do but so far you check
that box with that giant sharpie man
because he's going to be
he's going to be
an upper half quarterback minimum the
question is how high does he climb all
right i alluded to this earlier but i
didn't have time enough time to really
flesh it out the new england patriots
get the road warriors award because they
thumped the lions last night i know the
score doesn't matter in most cases but
31-3 suggests to me that bill belichick
is salty about the fact that the team
was three and five on the road last year
and think about it the super bowl
champions had a losing record away from
home in the regular season last year and
he talked he talked about that in the
context of joint practices earlier this
week that it's valuable to take practice
on the road because they're so conscious
of their struggles on the road last year
they lose in miami it seems like every
single year and they go to miami if i
recall correctly fairly early in the
2019 season i think that belichick has a
different energy and a different vibe
this year they've figured out how to
hold serve at home week after week after
week after week they now have to figure
out how to win more than three games on
the road and they're gonna be committed
to a week two after that game on sunday
night football against the steelers they
go back to miami he gets back together
with brian flores and i just i sensed
last night that there is an urgency to
this team this year to win games on the
road especially early in the season yeah
mike i mean oh shocker in new england's
thinking next level and doing next level
things i mean it's like it's just status
quo and yeah i mean that's what bill
does you know we had a weakness here
last year and he's going to attack it
and and make his team very aware of the
weakness and he's going to beat it in
their brain and tell him they got to
overcome it and i was going to use them
as one of my superlatives too mike
because i was gonna i was gonna throw
out a well-oiled machine or something
like that because it's just unreal i
mean they come out in the preseason game
one and i know you know tom brady's not
even out there and it's just brian hoyer
boom boom boom boom boom touchdown he
goes a few drives jared siddom comes in
it's boom boom boom boom boom touchdown
i mean it's just unreal
how well they're coached how they
execute all the time uh and you know hey
it was fun to see some of those young
guys like jared stood them and kill
harry you know show their their worth
here and then kill harry i expect is
going to have a very big role uh for tom
brady and josh mcdaniels in that pat's
offense
i i think the bottom line is this
because they were three and five at on
the road last year they had to go to
kansas city for the fc championship game
and i think bill belichick realizes how
close they came to losing that game you
go back to 2015 they had to go to denver
they lost that game in denver they have
to be able to get that one seed and
force the road to the super bowl through
their home stadium so all it takes is a
game here or a game there and i think
he's determined to not let that team
duplicate three and five on the road and
to not have to go back to kansas city
it's like apollo creed at the end of
rocky one there ain't going to be no
rematch right because i think apollo
knows the next time around they're going
to lose that when they got lucky to a
certain extent well they got lucky with
the toss of a coin ultimately and over
time they don't want to have to go back
to arrowhead stadium for the playoffs in
2019.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports